hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie guide I have a
couple of great suggestions for your
weekend movie watching both in theaters
and at home so let's start with a little
film called loving doin in there without
woman how much wash that's no good here
this is directed by jeff nichols who is
the same guy who had Midnight Special
out earlier this year amazing this is
based on a true story of Mildred and
Richard loving these two ended up
changing the Constitution in the 1960s
because of their interracial marriage I
have to admit when I first saw loving I
didn't exactly love it you know Jeff
Nichols is known for taking these big
concepts and telling them in a very
small way and I knew that going in but
because he made this so much just about
an ordinary marriage I felt like I
couldn't connect to it as emotionally as
I wanted to and I think I'm so used to
going into these kind of movies and
expecting certain beats and certain
emotional cues to really get you in the
spirit of things but my second time
around I really appreciated how small he
kept this movie because by making them
into just a ordinary everyday humdrum
marriage it actually makes it more
powerful because you think we'll why
can't they have their love because that
love is very similar to something I've
experienced rather than the kind of
Hollywood eyes version that could have
happened I got to sit down with my
fellow of the joel edgerton to talk a
little bit about loving here's a snippet
I think Jeff really understood that the
way to draw people's empathy into why we
shouldn't judge the private lives of any
two individuals is by inviting the
audience into that home and watching
what they just had to do from day to day
while fight fighting through this
obstacle so that by the time they get
what they want you feel like you know
them so well and and to not Hollywood
afire the move
yeah I think was a very smart choice and
you can see more of the interview with
Joel Edgerton and the rest of the cast
on fandango all access YouTube channel
this week I'm going to put a big awards
watch over this one for Joel Edgerton
and ruth negga in particular I think
it's a kind of movie in the kind of
performances that need to be rewarded
whoop whoop whoop is there anything you
like me to say to the Supreme Court
justices of the United States yeah tell
a judge I love my wife now to another
inspiring movie the documentary the
Eagle Huntress this is about a 13 year
old girl living in Mongolia who wants to
be an eagle hunter and by the way that's
not hunting eagles that's using Eagles
as hunting weapons she comes from a long
line of Eagle hunters 12 generations of
them but they were all men and so I love
seeing her ambition her passion and her
drive not to let her gender or anything
else get in the way of her dreams right
now it's going to be playing in New York
and LA but slowly it'll be rolled out to
other states so if you can see it and
see it is I recommend you do that
because this happens to be one of the
most beautiful walking documentaries
I've seen in a long time and another
documentary suggestion this one you can
watch at home tickled competitive
endurance tickling it was one of the
strangest sports I've seen so I told
Jana Brian media I'd like to do an
interview instead of getting a yes or no
I got this association with a homosexual
journalist is not something we will
embrace him on you
gay Kiwis regards Jane O'Brien media
this follows New Zealand journalist
David farrier who goes down a rabbit
hole of sorts when he discovers this
tickling competition now you might think
tickling sounds pretty innocent but
trust me this movie gets dark there's so
many twists and turns you have no idea
where it's going to end up and it's
absolutely compelling from start to
finish the thing that she hates the most
was no it was like a bomb went off your
phone number and your personal
information are entirely known and
subject to publication on the internet
all hell broke loose and I have to put
Awards watch over this one as well
because this is one of the 145
documentaries that have been selected as
possible Oscar nominations for best
documentary category and I really hope
it gets in we're shooting a documentary
I understand so you think you're doing
do you want to pick your dad requests
friend
my god oh my god so to recap in theaters
you can see the gentle drama loving or
the soulful documentary the Eagle
Huntress and at home don't forget to
watch tickled of fascinating and quite
disturbing documentary and don't forget
to write in the comments below which
indie films you've been watching and
loving lately I'm Alicia Malone I'll
catch you next week